Shawn O'Hara is the NFL Network analyst
former Super Bowl champ with the Giants
and joining us on the program Sean good
morning how are you
top of the morning to you Dan all right
what do you want to diet
what do you want to dive into here oh
man there's there's so much good action
you know I tell you the first couple
weeks so much sloppy football play it's
nice to finally see some some good teams
finally pull it all together so I'm game
for whatever all right I mean I think it
was good for the Giants to kind of get
their first win
you know we had five teams get their
first win this weekend starting off with
the Cleveland Browns so who doesn't love
Bud Light for everybody well let me
start with the Vikings losing to Buffalo
and then the Vikings got a short work
week they got the Rams coming up and I
don't know if they look past Buffalo but
how do you explain the bills coming in
with a rookie quarterback and you're a
17 point underdog and you get blown out
yeah I mean that right there that is the
beauty and also the craziness of the NFL
but Buffalo you know like I don't think
they had a whole lot of confidence and
coming into the game but all of a sudden
you make the plays you know you you get
a couple turnovers and and all of a
sudden now everybody's just got a
totally different vibe I think you know
Minnesota that that's kind of you know
for them you can always chalk up a
couple of games in the season as you
know what that was our clunker and you
know what maybe maybe we were you know a
little lackadaisical in the week and
just kind of you know didn't watch as
much film or you know didn't weren't as
sharp in practice so I think a lot of
times that's good for a team because it
can kind of rebound and bounce back but
you mentioned the short week so as a
player there's nothing better than
having a short week coming off of an
awful loss like that cuz you get to hit
to get back right back at it you don't
have to sit around for seven more days
the Giants getting the win in Houston
but I'm curious what they're able to
continue doing the guy I had high hopes
for the Giants I actually with all that
talent I thought that you know they
could do some damage this year and
they're doing damage to themselves
normally but what did you see yesterday
where's pure Giants fan you go you know
what there's a light at the end of the
well I think we saw what the team is
capable of when they're not beating
theirselves themselves as you just
mentioned like last week that didn't
look like football that looked like a
bunch of guys I've never practiced that
we're trying to figure things out in the
huddle and draw on things in the dirt
way too many mental assignments I mean
they had six acts last week against
Dallas and I think five of them were
probably mental busts one time they got
be physically they gave up four sacks
against Houston and I think of those
four you know one of them was a mental
breakdown so that they cleaned all that
up but JJ Watt you know he's gonna get
his especially you throw out a young guy
like Chad wheeler out there at tackle so
you expect some of those plays to happen
but we saw the Giants just to me that
offense looked more balanced they ran
the football a lot more against Dallas
eight of the first ten plays were pass
plays and I didn't like that especially
when you have an offensive line that's
trying to still figure each other out
still building chemistry so going down
to Houston with a new center in
Giangreco who locally played a lot of
football
he started 70 games in his career so
he's a veteran from that standpoint but
he's you know starting at center for a
jalapeño who got her got her wheelers in
a right tackle he's a second year guy
and I thought they just they stuck with
the run the run game worked better they
moved the pocket a little bit and the
offense finally had rhythm so that's I
think that's a good sign for the Giants
I think we have all seen in just a
couple of weeks how explosive say Quan
Barkley is and you can't give that kid
the ball enough he the first guys not
bring him down we all know that but I
think he just he does a great job of
setting up blocks he's got a great
Le'Veon Bell like patience to him
certainly helps when you have that when
you have that burst button but I think
the real big concern to me Dan is the
defense you know we saw them get after
deshaun Watson a little bit I mean part
of that's because the Texans offensive
line is struggling man they're their
right tackle Davenport he's giving up
more pressure than any tackle in the
league right now
deshaun Watson looks like he's
struggling with accuracy so I think for
the Giants defense to really step
forward they've done a great job as a
run they need Olivia
to get back so they can get a little bit
of a pass rush how does it not work out
for the Rams this year well I think
everybody's holding their breath right
now for Marcus Peters you know seeing
him go down you know when you look at
this team on paper they're a shoo-in for
the Super Bowl when you look at the
talent when you look at both sides of
the ball how explosive they can be
really it's to health you know get if
they can get if they can get through
this first half of the season clean and
not sustain any long-term injuries you
know I don't see any reason why they're
not the number one seed in the NFC
offensively just to think how much more
explosive they got this awesome with
Brandon cooks obviously Todd Gurley is
doing his thing but they're just so hard
to keep up with and you know you look up
it reminds me wouldn't lease to play the
philippi goals and and Amy Reed was so
good to start out the game and I
remember there were so many times we
playing the birds and you look up and
it's halfway through the first quarter
or just to start a second quarter and
you're down 14 enough and already and
when you can do that like the Rams are
doing you know that's just I mean it's a
great way to play football and as
offensive lineman I think they're all
lines playing great they're doing a
great job running the football and when
you get up early you get you get to do
that but but then defensively to let
those guys just unleash hell on the
other posing quarterback that's that's
great football and it's probably fun to
watch for all the Rams fans you Shawn
O'Hara NFL Network analyst former Super
Bowl champ of the Giants joining a Stan
Patrick show what should clay matthews
do man I'm frustrated for him and
defensive lineman will tell you that man
that you know they're always getting
held on every play and and you know
they're they're they're on the lead
counsel for the 80-bit committee and so
normally I'm not sticking up for them
and I'm you know I don't I don't bow for
them but in this case I mean I don't
know what more he's got to do you
watched that play this weekend the hit
on on Kirk Cousins last weekend there
they're not militia hits militia says I
think the rule was put in place when we
all saw Aaron Rodgers go get ruined
into his collarbone and and and now he's
out for the year everybody said okay
look we've got to do more to protect the
quarterbacks and take those hits out of
the game I don't think anybody argues
that but when you see clean sacks and I
wasn't a quarterback hit that wasn't a
pressure as the quarterback was getting
rid of the ball I think to me there's a
difference if if the quarterback has
gotten rid of the football and you hit
him and drive him into the ground
I get that being a penalty because the
ball is gone but if it's a sack if the
quarterback has the ball he's a ball
carrier and I don't know how you take
him to the ground and not land on top of
them in some way shape or form now you
can we can all see if a defensive
lineman puts a little extra hot sauce on
it if he's literally trying to land on
him or picking him up and slamming him
clay didn't do that either time so I
think he got screwed you know I think
the sad thing is that nobody's come out
and said hey look we need to call this
better I think they've given these
referees so much so much to handle as a
judgment call I think at the speed of
the game and there's times where we walk
we all watch it I mean you're you're
you're and they're watching it in
slow-mo and you're like man that's dicey
that's in slow motion so yeah I think we
need to change the referees uniforms I
don't think they should wear black and
white anymore there's too much gray out
there on the field give them great
uniforms referees are supposed to have
black and white calls and it's not
anymore so given new uniforms wow that's
meta that's deep sorry is it too early
to get deep yeah especially from you I
mean I'm not surprised yeah I mean I'm a
little surprised this early from you
what well usually when I'm in the studio
I get to put my hands on people oh you
know I got to use my brain this time I
guess all right what can the Steelers if
they are shopping lady on bail what do
you think you can get in return for lady
on bail well I doubt they're gonna get
what they would like you know I mean if
you traded lady on bail this offseason
you know we saw Brandon cooks get
treated he got a first-round pick we
obviously saw what Khalil Mack got
traded for there's no way anybody's
gonna give up
what Chicago gave up for Khalil Mack to
first rounds and I think our future
second
that's just you know it's not gonna
happen I think the one thing that lay
beyond bill has against him is he's got
a couple of injuries he's they've ridden
him hard so I think a lot of teams are
kind of worried about how much does he
have left so I think to sit there and
say you know hey we've fielded some
offers that may be true I don't know
what that offers for I mean if somebody
called up and said hey would you you
know if we gave you a second round pick
next year would you trade them you know
I mean sure that's an offer I don't know
if that's kind of more the thing I
always question is is this the team kind
of playing hey look you know we'll let's
get the ball rolling on this we want to
create a little bit of a trade value
let's see where it's out there and let's
see if anybody I were it's you know a
little pressure from from Le'Veon Bell
side saying hey look we've got a couple
teams that would be in trading and if
they're floating all this out there so I
think maybe on bells are stood but I
think if you're gonna trade for them you
also got to realize it you might not be
ready to play the first couple weeks so
how much are you going to get out of
them this year and he's only going to
agree to it if you're gonna agree to a
long-term deal that would be my guess
when do you start to get concerned if
you're a Patriots fan
I don't think Patriots fans are ever
really concerned in September you know
we've seen them you know wet the bed
before and I think I remember that
Kansas City game a couple years ago they
looked awful and people were saying well
this is it Tom Brady that's it he's done
he's aging and you know that might have
been the we're on to Cincinnati quote I
never I feel like September is you know
that's kind of like a dating period
right you don't you're just dating
somebody you don't want to worry about
labels you know are we girlfriend or we
are we serious I could it's a
no-judgment phase and you just you're
play football you don't judge what are
we as a team are we are we a team are we
an average team just play ball on
September and then let October kind of
become now the relationships getting a
little more serious and now let's start
talking about a label but for New
England it they're always one of the
best at correcting things and as the
season moves along at getting rid of all
the bad football I think last night was
an aberration more than
and what I would expect to be the norm
I'm glad you got up with us it's good to
talk to you again Sean will hopefully
get you in studio so you can put your
hands on one of the day Nets oh I can't
wait it would love that
thank you got some sleep man Thank You
Sean
that's a Shawn O'Hara NFL Network
analyst and won a couple of Super Bowls
with the Giants for more Dan Patrick
show to the audience channel 239 on
DirecTV or download the Dan Patrick show
app
[Music]